Hillary Clinton has a ton of people furious
with her and for good reason because she said
nobody likes Bernie Sanders.
Now I'm going to give you the context.
I'm going to give you the reaction to the
analysis, everything, but notice that it's
all happening faster and faster.
Now the attacks on Bernie Sanders, uh, and,
and now I'm going to take a position that
might shock you here.
I think it might be true that Bernie Sanders
is not the most well-liked guy by his colleagues,
but I don't think it matters one damn bit.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about
today.
There's an upcoming documentary.
Uh, it's a series called Hillary.
And in the series Hillary Clinton has asked
about Bernie Sanders and as first reported
by the Hollywood reporter and since widely,
uh, widely corroborated, including by Hillary
Clinton, Hillary Clinton said, quote, he was
in Congress for years.
He had one Senator support him.
Nobody likes him, nobody wants to work with
him.
He got nothing done.
He was a career politician.
It's all just bologna.
And I feel so bad that people got sucked into
it.
Now, of course, the immediate question before
we get into the, the, the lack of the irresponsibility
of this was, is Hillary saying that if Bernie
is the nominee, she would not support Bernie
over Donald Trump?
Her answer, when she was recently asked about
it was, quote, I'm not going to go there yet.
We're still in a very vigorous primary season.
I will say, however, that it's not only him,
it's the culture around him.
It's his leadership team.
It's his prominent supporters.
It's his online Bernie bros and their relentless
attacks on lots of his competitors, particularly
the women.
This is how we lose.
Okay?
There's a whole bunch of analyses that we
could do.
This is how we lose, once again, this is the
top level analysis.
This is the type of division that I'm talking
about.
This applies to Hillary doing it to Bernie.
This supplies to people saying, I wouldn't
vote Biden no matter what I, uh, to people
attacking Warren and saying, if it's Warren
over Bernie, I don't want Warren cause she
voted in favor of more funding for, for, uh,
the, the military.
It applies to all of it.
Okay?
This is how we lose and we can talk about
the specifics of what being said here.
And here's my take.
I think it's probably true that Bernie is
not the most well liked guy within the house
and Senate.
I've spoken to people who have traveled with
Bernie quite a bit in a, uh, in a formal role
and they've said he's difficult when it comes
to his relationships with the house and Senate.
He's not that well liked.
Who cares?
Okay.
What matters are two things.
What are Bernie's policies?
Who cares if Joe mansion doesn't like Bernie?
If Bernie is going to fix healthcare, okay,
well I don't care.
Do you care?
Why does Hillary care?
What matters is, is what Hillary Clinton is
doing, going to help remove Donald Trump or
not.
It's not.
It's going to help reelect Donald Trump.
And number two, Bernie's policy.
What would he do for people without healthcare?
The same thing for Elizabeth Warren or for
Joe Biden or whatever.
Are they better than Donald Trump?
The answer is yes.
Are we taking actions that will make it more
likely that Donald Trump gets reelected?
If the answer is yes, don't do it.
Okay.
That's the test.
Uh, Bernie, by the way, all but admits this
about himself.
What I mean is if you watch the video, so
the New York times recently endorsed, um,
Amy Klobuchar and Elizabeth Warren and, um,
they filmed a bunch of interviews where they
met with the candidates and when they put
out a video, uh, from their conversation with
Bernie Sanders, they asked Bernie about his
weaknesses.
And Bernie says, I'm not the guy.
This is my paraphrasing.
I'm not the guy who hobnobs.
I'm not the guy who, I think Bernie said,
who's going to call you on your birthday.
He's not socially a pleasure to be around
is what Bernie Sanders is saying.
And this is very similar to what Hillary Clinton
is saying.
He was not well liked by uh, uh, people in
the house and Senate.
It's probably true, but it's irrelevant and
it's embarrassing for Hillary Clinton to be
pulling it out now and to be playing coy about
whether she'd support Bernie if he's the nominee.
It's not too soon to say I'd support Bernie
if he's the nominee.
The first votes are going to be cast in a
few days.
So what do we do?
The 22nd?
The first votes will be cast in, you know,
a couple of weeks or whatever.
Um, it, it's very easy to say I will support
the eventual democratic nominee.
The fact that Hillary Clinton didn't say that
is pathetic.
So when I say I still believe the most likely
scenario is a Biden nomination and a loss
to Trump in November.
This type of garbage, we'll guarantee it.
Right?
Ignorant Trumpists who love the guy is part
of it.
There are many parts of it, but this is what
I committed not to participate in.
When we first covered the primary and we first
covered the candidates that were running and
also the headlines about what Hillary said
are totally misleading and out of context,
the headlines say, Hillary says, nobody likes
Bernie.
It suggests she's talking about people like
just random people.
She's talking about senators and legislators.
She may be right.
She may be wrong.
From what I've heard, she's probably right,
but it's a relevant, it's irrelevant to whether
Bernie has the right ideas for making the
country better.
It's irrelevant to whether Bernie is better
than Trump and the fact that Hillary Clinton
is adding idiocy to idiocy saying, nobody
likes Bernie.
Okay, that, that it, even if it's true, it's
probably a misstep strategically, but then
when she's asked, but will you vote for him?
Will you support him if he's the nominee and
she says, it's too early to talk about that.
This is how we guarantee that Donald Trump
is reelected in November.
I'm not going to participate in it.
Okay, I'm a progressive.
I'm going to support a progressive.
I'm going to support the eventual democratic
nominee with the goal of removing Trump and
starting to wake up from the nightmare that
has been, uh, the first and hopefully only
term of president Donald Trump.
Let me know what you think.
We'll be talking about this on our Instagram
page.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at the David Pakman show.
While you're there, follow
me@daviddotactonaswellthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.